[Music]
it's et's social study what the stars
are posting online we could get that
happen Nicki Minaj is not shy about
flaunting her curves the rapper posted a
series of bootylicious pics in London
rocking a sheer bodysuit knee high heels
and Rapunzel long hair then Nicki caused
quite a scene on the streets of the
England capital as she appeared to shoot
a music video wearing a bejeweled
headdress and fur more stars showing
some skin Demi Lovato goes topless for a
mid fitting nap then there's Emily
Ratajkowski baring her buns in Mexico
the model stripped down to nothing to go
skinny-dipping during her tropical
getaway it's a celebration of femininity
it's a celebration of beauty meanwhile
Selena Gomez and the weekend take their
romance to new heights in Toronto the
power couple enjoyed a romantic trip to
the weekend's hometown spending a day at
ripley's aquarium of canada the star boy
singer shared a series of adorable pics
and videos of Selena admiring the
aquatic venue
[Music]